Christmas it's the most wasteful time of
year hundreds of thousands of tons of
festive packaging nearly 230,000 miles
of wrapping paper shucked the holiday
leads to 100 million black bags full of
packaging and not nearly enough of this
mountain gets used again thanks to
convert convoluted regulations and the
wrong materials used like glitter and
plastic I'm not perfect I shop online
and I have a fur Christmas tree but I
also reuse wrapping paper
I recycle card and I am the queen of the
turkey casserole my festive message when
it comes to the waste we should all be
more of a Grinch or Scrooge this
Christmas well it's cool appreciate that
but remember scooch ended up being quite
a nice bloke yeah that's where that's
where they carry on but you don't think
that it's christmas christmas is a time
of joy it's a time of fun it's a time
when people why do you want to I mean we
have problems with waste all year round
why do you now want to make a big budget
the enormous increase in waste over
Christmas I mean we if you look outside
on the street after after Christmas I
mean there are mountains of rubbish and
tart and you know what it's true we're
all individually responsible we can
reuse you know reuse recycle
don't you know basically give you a good
tip right if you can scrunch it you can
recycle it which I'm afraid which means
that this probably isn't there are tons
of things you can do well Nick you asked
about what we can all do to reduce
packaging but what about the
manufacturers and retailers I didn't
think it would be Christmas without some
sort of family game so welcome to
Rachel's reindeer quiz
oh right so I have some white boards for
the panel where you were gonna write
your answers to three questions you have
10 seconds for each question fantastic
here we go so the first question wrong
quizzes is about packaging all right
look at this packet of lush Ferrero
Rocher and tell me what percentage of
this product is packaging clock starts
now
panel I need your answers oh you've all
gone very high I must say it's 42
percent you made it
are you ready for this Thornton's
continental continental selection you
have ten seconds starting now what
percentage of this box is packaging it's
gone heart Nick's got 41 Greg screwed 40
Carol 39 halfway let's have it 60% well
the answer is it's 30% so Carol is our
festival these are actually these ones
these are the mint Lindor festive
baubles what percentage is packaging
panel okay
go very quick on the draw all of you
right Nick 55 pathways 49 Carroll's 28
sent Greg Koch Scrooge's 30% and the
answer is a surprisingly modest and slim
line 11.5% is a seasonal favorite super
who hasn't got a box of chocolates I
mean they are really spoiling us to the
path you've got the lovely angel costume
we're doing that because we're doing
that because manufacture should what's
the point of that was you obviously
don't seem for area right not a look we
don't want to single that individual
because actually I love a Ferrero Rocher
near the ambassador's reception when you
had them blue handed but the problem is
refer they can't even recycle this
packaging this is a matte field base but
the bottom line is written one of us as
individuals whatever we do it doesn't
matter until industry the government and
supermarkets get on board
you know supermarkets all signed a
plastic pact this year so but no but you
know hey the thing is it's
no it's voluntary they're not made to do
it so they can they can do it or not so
we're not very it should being seen
there is a plastic bag tax it's not
volunteer no plastic bag tag it's called
the plastic packed our and CE Marking
what it is about the supermarkets are
supposed to get rid of single-use
packaging where they can ask you a
question can I ask the panel question I
don't because this was part mentioned
some measures that were introduced by
Michael Gove he wants to change the way
that he wants firms to be fined yes and
he wants to restore to the high street
someone needs to turn there isn't a high
street electrical repair shops yes so
that you take your toaster or your
vacuum clean
when did you last get a small item like
a kettle or an iron you take a toaster
to be repaired we now live in my coffee
grinder and I've just replaced my
nutribullet because they both packed it
in and it's easier to order two more
probably thirty quid a cake shop to get
them finished guys always tell you the
guys who come to fix your washing
machine that's gone wrong or you say
forget it because they only make them to
last five years that's actually not just
manufacturers because we are talking
about Christmas and there's lots of
things that we do like for example how
many of you recycled your wrapping paper
when we got a Secret Santa gifts and
I've got a statistic for you cards one
tree makes an average of 3,000 Christmas
cards that's only enough for a hundred
and seventy-six people to send out their
Christmas cards hundreds an institution
I personally haven't grown up quite
enough yet to sing Christmas cards but
she's making a Justine receive two of
cars each so now it's in the I get made
to be the low forties and I can I
receive I send out about 30 or and it'll
be less next year
well have you going we're not gonna make
a difference as individuals until
industry is I mean they've got the
government but it starts with you
comes to take individual responsibility
there's you can yes with the industry
not putting around your shoulder the
plastic fingers isn't is big this year
and it's becoming bigger and I suspect
in five years time it will have made a
significant change but it doesn't happen
overnight
ever